ahí vemos que bolsonaro ha salido
totalmente reforzado porque ha
conseguido elegir a ocho senadores
frente a los cuatro del partido de los
trabajadores Y entonces en el senado
tendrá el grupo parlamentario más grande
de su historia nos referimos al partido
liberal que representa a bolso lo mismo
pasa en el congreso donde han elegido a
diputados según los datos parciales y
tendrán también el grupo parlamentario
más fuerte lo que es muy importante en
un país que no es 100% presidencial
Brasil es un semi presidencialismo donde
las dos cámaras del parlamento tienen un
peso muy grande otro dato que muestra
Cuánto bolsionar es fuerte todos sus ex
aliados que se han alejado de él no han
sido elegidos en el congreso ni en el
senado y finalmente Sergio Moro el juez
que mandó Lula a la cárcel ha sido
elegido como senador junto a otros
representa de la investigación la
bachata lo que también demuestra que una
parte de Brasil no se fía de Lula y no
ha olvidado los escándalos de corrupción